este es mi primer vídeo de álgebra
lineal me siento muy feliz porque por
fin vamos a tocar temas acerca de
álgebra lineal es una parte de la
matemática muy importante y bueno en el
álgebra lineal a los dioses o las 'vacas
sagradas' del álgebra lineal lo que
hacen es agarrar cosas muy sencillas por
eso vamos trabaja con cosas muy
sencillas pero hablarlo en un lenguaje
un poco complicado por lo tanto es muy
importante que ustedes pongan bastante
atención porque aunque las cosas son
fáciles y vamos a ver todo con términos
muy sencillos se puede complicar en un
futuro hablando de la anotación pero
bueno para empezar me gustaría hablar
acerca de los números reales entonces
vamos a poner aquí los números reales y
de hecho se denotan con una erre
mayúscula con dos palitos en un
principio así se ponen en los libros o
también se ponen como una mayúscula
gorda
entonces fíjense bien una era mayúscula
remarcada o una r mayúscula
gruesa y bueno este es el conjunto de
los números reales
de todos los números reales y si tú me
preguntas bueno quiénes son los números
reales yo te podría decir varias
definiciones de los números reales y se
me pueden ocurrir varias ideas de cómo
definir a los números reales sin embargo
a mí me gusta mucho ver a los números
reales como todos los números que has
visto de hecho todos los números que
viste en un principio hasta que llegaste
a los complejos es decir son todos los
números que conoces excepto los
complejos a mí me gusta ver así a los
números reales todos excepto los
complejos por lo tanto raíz de 2 es un
número real 2 es un número real pi es un
número real 3 es un número real tres
cuartos es un número real - tres cuartos
estos números real menos 3 es un número
real pero uno más 2 y este no es un
número real porque tiene una parte
imaginaria y por lo tanto es un número
complejo entonces son todos excepto los
números complejos es decir todos los
números que tú te sabías hasta que te
topas con los imaginarios y a partir de
ahí todo cambió pero bueno ahora quiero
hablarles acerca de la idea de erre
elevado a la l
de los números reales elevados a la n
quien va a ser este conjunto
rn bueno muchos libros traen esta
anotación una r mayúscula con dos
palitos elevado a la n y seguramente tú
te estás imaginando que son todos los
números reales elevados a la potencia n
y en cierta forma es algo así pero no
tan sencillo y no es tal cual así que
mejor pensemos los de esta manera vamos
a pensar en un caso más sencillo en r 2
r2 es un conjunto pero que conjunto
bueno vamos a definirlo y lo puede
definir de varias maneras pero voy a
intentar definirlo así tomemos a dos
números x1 y x2 son dos números y
entonces r 2 es el conjunto de todos los
números x1 y x2 es decir una duplán de
números aquí lo voy a escribir que estén
ordenados y eso es muy importante es una
dupla de números o una pareja de números
tales que estén ordenados y el orden
aquí es importantísimo déjenme
escribirlo por aquí x1 y x2 tienen que
cumplir que además de que son un par de
números
tu plan tienen que tener un cierto orden
por lo tanto voy a poner que rn y r2
está ordenado y qué quiere decir eso que
si nosotros tomamos por ejemplo el 12
esto no va a ser igual a tener el 21
esto es lo que implica el orden que el
12 y el 21 no son iguales son bichos
distintos y bueno entonces tenemos las
duplas de números x1 y x2 que son
parejas de números ordenadas tales que
esta línea vertical que tengo aquí
significa tales que o que cumplen esta
cierta propiedad ojo van a ser tales que
o que cumplen esta cierta propiedad y
que propiedad bueno cambiamos al color
morado claro y recordemos tengan que ser
dúplex de números que además tengan un
orden y tienen que tener la siguiente
propiedad que es la más importante la
propiedad de que x
existe en los números reales este
símbolo que yo tengo aquí se llama
existe o es un miembro de equis y es un
miembro o existe en los números reales
esto para y menor o igual a 2 y mayor o
igual a 1 por lo tanto vamos a
escribirlo como para y que está entre 2
en este caso y entre 1 mayor o igual a 1
y menor o igual a 2 este tiene que ser
un entero eso es muy importante ahora sí
ya que tengo una definición de lo que
significa r2 y de hecho es una de las
tantas definiciones que yo pueda tomar
ahorita se me ocurre otra que tal vez
sería mucho más sencilla poner la r2 es
igual al conjunto de duplas de números
x1 y x2 ordenados tales que cumplan un
siguiente x1 y x2 los dos tienen que ser
miembros o tienen que existir en los
números reales por lo tanto me voy a
tomar duplas de números tales que tanto
uno como el otro estén en los números
reales por ejemplo 1 2 y el 2 1 y bueno
este cuadrado o este 2 que está de súper
índice lo que significa es que tenemos a
r2 y nosotros en un principio pensamos
que era tal vez una potencia y en cierta
forma te dije que era una potencia
porque verlo así supongamos que tenemos
a todo
reales y bueno me vas a decir que son
una infinidad de números reales pero
vamos a imaginar que tenemos solamente
100 números reales entonces tenemos 100
números reales en la primera casilla
tenemos una posibilidad vamos a ponerlo
en la primera coordenada tenemos una
posibilidad de 100 porque tenemos sin
números reales en este caso vamos a
suponer que son 100 números reales
tenemos 100 posibilidades de escoger a
un número real y ponerlo aquí y entonces
en la segunda coordenada también
tendríamos otras 100 posibilidades de
poner un número aquí por lo tanto es re
cuadrada tendremos 100% posibilidades de
tomar estas duplas en r2 por lo tanto
tendríamos un cuadrado de posibilidades
cien por cien es el cuadrado de
posibilidades de las posibilidades que
teníamos inicialmente cuando solamente
tenemos los números reales sin embargo
los números reales son infinitos
entonces imagínate r2 tiene una
infinidad de infinidades de
posibilidades de tomar valores y aunque
ahorita no me quiero meter en problemas
de cardinal y that ni de conteo
imagínate
r2 tiene una infinidad por una infinidad
de
o sea una infinidad mucho más grande
pero bueno ahora pensemos en r3 r3 lo
voy a definir de la misma forma r3 es el
conjunto de las ternas de números x 1 x
2 y x 3 en este caso van a ser ahora
tres números que estén ordenados tales
que cada uno de esos números existen los
números reales y bueno también podemos
pensar en r1 r uno es solamente un
número es una coordenada por lo tanto
tendríamos un número que esté en los
números reales y por lo tanto r uno es
lo mismo que los números reales fíjense
en aquí tengo el cero y aquí vamos a
tomar aquí vamos a tomar a uno son
números reales y aquí también puede ser
en cada una de estas coordenadas como
podemos tomar valores en los números
reales podemos tener aquí
a uno podríamos por ejemplo tener el
valor 10 coma pi o el punto como a uno
como aquí lo que sea y al final cuando
estamos hablando de r2 estamos hablando
de puntos en un plano cartesiano en dos
dimensiones mientras que cuando estamos
hablando de r3 estamos hablando de
puntos pero en esta ocasión en un
espacio es decir en tres dimensiones
ahora bien en este vídeo quiero ver una
tercera definición quiero ver lo que es
un vector y bueno un vector lo hemos
visto antes recuerdas en física era algo
que tenía magnitud y dirección hay veces
que en cálculo lo hemos trazado pero en
esta ocasión quiero ser muy formal y muy
abstracto y muy extenso con este vector
con la definición de vector porque la
belleza del álgebra lineal es que no
sólo se aplica a cosas como la física
bueno de hecho si se aplica cosas como
la física y además como la física pero
no se limitan el álgebra lineal se puede
aplicar a todo pero no solo a gráficas
tres dimensiones etcétera porque bueno
el punto es que voy a hacer más
abstracto un vector en rn es lo que
quiero definir a continuación y bueno ya
definimos r2 y r3 pero no hemos definido
rn creo que sería muy bueno definir lo
que es rn antes de ver lo que es un
vector en rn entonces voy a llamar a rn
al conjunto de bueno que serán duplas
ternas en este caso van a ser n hadas de
números es decir x1
está tratada hasta x n tenemos n
entradas aquí n coordenadas aquí tal que
tiene que ser un conjunto ordenado de n
números que existen en los reales una en
nada de números bueno esta línea de
números tales que xy existe o es un
miembro de los números reales y esto
para y desde igual a uno hasta iguala en
es decir para y mayor o igual a 1 y
menor o igual a en esto qué quiere decir
que bueno que x 1 es un número real x 2
es un número real x 3 el número real
todos son números reales y bueno si en
r2 tendríamos una dupla de números aquí
tenemos una en nada de números pero
todos tienen que estar en los números
reales y es ordenado y bueno ahora sí
que es un vector en rn voy a definir un
vector en rn como unam bueno de hecho es
un caso particular de estas entradas un
vector en rn lo puede definir como una
lista ordenada una lista ordenada de n
real es una lista ordenada de números
reales así voy a definir vector en rn y
ojo como estamos en rn necesitamos n
números y bueno hay muchas mutaciones
para poner el vector en rn por ejemplo
lo pueden poner a gas y también con
paréntesis o termino pueden poner con
corchetes
es más pensemos en un vector nr 2n r2 se
vería algo así como x 1 x dos bebés que
lo ponen así x1 y x2 no sé hay varias
representaciones de un vector pero lo
que es importante es que este vector en
rn o en r 2 cuando lo quieran tomar es
una lista es como un caso particular de
estas n hadas de números es una lista de
números reales y bueno muchas veces
pueden como columnas otras veces como
renglones pero vamos a ver un caso
particular fíjense bien voy a tomar este
vector ven que va a ser mi vector b1 b2
b3 b4 hasta bn tal es que cada una de
estas entradas o cada uno de estos
componentes es un número real b 1 es un
número real es un miembro de los números
de 2 también es un número real es un
miembro de los números reales etcétera y
bueno a cada una de estas entradas de un
vector se le conoce como componentes del
vector b 2 es un componente de este
vector y casi siempre para diferenciar
un vector de un número se pone un vector
con una línea arriba o en dado caso un
vector con un ave gorda por lo tanto
vamos a poner de gorda o b negrita o
verde marcada como no quiera llamar el
vector remarcado tiene varios
componentes y b1 b2 b3 b4 etcétera
etcétera son componentes de ese vector y
bueno a continuación lo que quiero ver
es definir algunas operaciones con este
vector y yo voy a definir estas
operaciones de una cierta manera de una
manera que nos va a servir pero tú
podrías definir estas mismas operaciones
que por cierto una de ellas es la suma
de otra manera y también podría servir
así es como se define en convenciones de
matemáticas la suma de dos vectores voy
a tomar dos vectores y cómo se define la
suma y estas construcciones y estas
definiciones son
en ciudades arbitrarias hechas por el
ser humano así que no te desanimes
pronto podrás hacer todos tus propias
definiciones como definimos la suma de
dos vectores así que tomemos el vector
am vamos a ponerlo a grueso ha remarcado
a gordon a base del delta de a1 a2 hasta
a n porque estamos hablando de vectores
en rn y después me voy a tomar otro
vector voy a sumar dos vectores y por lo
tanto me voy a tomar el vector b b gordo
b grueso b q no quieras tomar ya que
tenemos b1 b2 hasta de n muy bien como
definió la suma de estos dos vectores la
suma de a más bien entonces lo voy a
poner fin a más b y es una suma de
vectores por lo tanto voy a poner a a un
poco más gruesa más ve un poco más
gruesa está definida como la suma la
suma de cada uno de sus correspondientes
componentes es decir aún no lo voy a
sumar con b 1 a 1 + b 1 a 2 lo voy a
sumar con b 2 a 2 más de 2 y así
sucesivamente hasta llegar aa n que lo
voy a sumar con b n así se define la
suma así que vamos a verlo con un
ejemplo porque tal vez está un poco
abstracto y no entiendas bien un bien
que está pasando pero juega un ejemplo
te va a quedar mucho más claro
supongamos que yo tengo el siguiente
vector vamos a tomarnos al vector dos
menos uno ya éste le voy a sumar el otro
vector que va a ser el 3-2 el vector 3-2
como sumo estos dos lectores
bueno pues la suma es componente a
componente el primer componente más el
primer componente me va a dar 2 + 3 lo
cual me da 5 y después el segundo
componente más el segundo componente lo
cual me va a dar menos 12 que es 1 y
bueno creo que con esto ya queda mucho
más claro como defino la suma de dos
vectores ahora voy a definir lo que es
la multiplicación por un escalar la
multiplicación escalar o la
multiplicación por un escalar así que
pensemos en un número escalar un número
escalar es a que el número real esto
simple esencialmente un número que
existe en los reales como puedo yo
multiplicar a un número que externó
reales x
todo un vector entonces fíjense bien
este va a ser mi número escalar c y lo
voy a multiplicar por el vector am
entonces aa la tengo que dibujar un poco
más gruesa y entonces se ve claramente
que ese es un escalar y ya es un vector
entonces defina la multiplicación por
una escalar
bueno aquí tenemos el vector am a1 a2
hasta n y cuando yo multiplico por sé
que es una escalar lo único que voy a
hacer es multiplicar hace por todos y
cada uno de los componentes es decir voy
a multiplicarse por a uno a separados
hace por a tres hasta se porta n por
ejemplo vamos a verlo con un ejemplo
para que nos quede mucho más claro tengo
a menos tres y lo voy a multiplicar por
el vector de tres componentes el vector
ping va a ser menos 2
como multiplico a este número escalar
por este vector vamos a usar la
definición que acabamos de ver bueno
pues lo único que tengo que hacer es
multiplicar a tres por cada uno de los
componentes por lo tanto no va a quedar
menos tres por el primer componente que
spears me queda menos 3 pib menos 3 por
menos 2 me da 6 positivos y menos 3 por
0 me va a dar 0
estoy multiplicando menos 3 por cada uno
de los componentes y así defino también
la multiplicación por escalar ya tengo
otra definición y bueno ya que todavía
tengo un poquito de tiempo quiero
definir también un vector que es muy
importante voy a definir al vector 0 o
el 0 vector el 0 vector es aquel vector
tal que cumple lo siguiente ojo estoy
hablando en rn es aquel vector que todos
sus componentes son 0 que todas sus
entradas un 0 0 0 0 0 0 y como es un
vector en rn tiene n componentes y por
lo tanto tiene n ceros a dentro
bueno esta es una pequeña definición y
ya con todo esto espero ponerte a pensar
un poco
acerca de qué es un vector qué es rn
cómo se define la suma como es el vector
0 también como definimos la
multiplicación por escalar etcétera y en
el siguiente vídeo voy a profundizar un
poco más esta idea